soir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france ce soir alors est
ce que pour vous la suspension des
allocations est la meilleure solution
pour combattre l'absentéisme scolaire
dans ma porte est donc là non je pense
que c'est pas la bonne solution et
d'ailleurs et eu déjà une tentacule par
exemple 2011 la droite l'avait mis en
place souligne eric schmidt avait été
retiré en 2013 car à gauche étaient
arrivés et les études qui ont suivi ce
dispositif montre que par exemple 77%
des familles qui avaient vu dans la
location en tirer dessus de la fuite
mais dont on était parvenu à l'école
donc on est un dispositif qui n'est pas
efficace qu'il en prenne pas de
solutions concrètes et qu'il pas de plus
mettez des family populaire on ajoute la
lumière la misère qu'on comprend pas
bien pourquoi
en supprimant des vocations ensuite on a
des ressources
on va permettre à des familles
d'accompagner meurt d'envié de répondre
aujourd'hui à la hauteur des enjeux
l'atrébate est un sujet sérieux qui
mérite les réponses politiques à la hong
et choix sur un effet n'en fait pas la
première fois en 2000 il abdellah la
droite a essayé de le faire passer au
sénat par le polyvalent bangert avait
été retoquée aujourd'hui on voit que le
point haut du clocher par entrée de
gamme une bonne nouvelle alors on voit
que c'est quand même une loi dans son
ensemble qui est en tout cas entretien
faux clivages gauche droite justement
françois durovray puisque c'est votre
camp qui a porté ce vote est bon
justement quel est l'intérêt pour vous
d'une telle mesure
d'abord il faut rappeler que les
allocations qui sont accordées aux
familles le son pur dans un objectif
global au niveau national de natalité
mais aussi pour aider les parents dans
leur mission d'éducation l'obligation
scolaire et heureusement et j'espère que
nous partageons au moins cela avec
monsieur porte s et l'obligation
scolaire s'impose à tous aux élèves mais
évidemment à leurs parents d'évidence
nous observons et notamment dans un
certain nombre de collèges à niveau
d'absentéisme et nous avions mis en
place en 2008 ce système de suspension
d'allocations qui évidemment une mesure
extrême
mais pour instaurer un dialogue avec les
familles et montrer qu'il peut y avoir
la contrainte de la subvention et
contrairement à ce qu'indique et
monsieur portait sud alors cette mesure
est efficace puisque sur 6000 cas
d'absentéisme qui avaient été remontés
par les établissements scolaires auprès
des inspections
il y a eu au final cinquante et une
suspension d'allocations
ce qui montre que le dialogue avait
permis de réduire considérablement
l'absentéisme scolaire est le chiffre
qui a été cité de 77% se base uniquement
sur les cinquante et une suspension réel
d'allocations donc vous voyez bien que
là elle nous avons sauvé des enfants
tout simplement par la menace de 7 2 7
de suspension d'allocations qui est une
usure humaniste
alors c'est quoi c'est pas sûr que cette
suspension des allocations en cas
d'absentéisme passant puisque le porte
parole du gouvernement des brêles at
elle affirmé c'est une solution qui ne
sera pas retenu dans ma porte
j'évoquais tout à l'heure mais je ne
peux pas en tant que c'est une mesure
humanitaire et enfin deux ans fragile il
des populations qui sont déjà dans la
difficulté
et contrairement en était différente en
deux les classes populaires et ont pris
l'attaché à l'école vous faire tâche est
que la banque allait à l'école c'est
quelque chose qu'ils réussissent
aujourd'hui on est un discours sur
dorothy de plus en plus étroit que
l'amendement il vise pas à lutter de
façon efficiente contre l'absentéisme à
l'école vit juste un objectif
idéologique à faire fort que les
familles populaires gens responsables du
chantier de la santé y compris
qu'aujourd'hui la 30e' à l'école une
récente a eu pendant lesquelles
familiale ya divers facteurs seconde est
aujourd'hui pour lutter contre ça il
faut avoir plus de médiateur plus de
soutien scolaire plus de psychologues
plus de moyens humains pour accompagner
ces candidats et c'est pas en ajoutant
les dictateurs de la misère la lumière
et en précarisant des gens qui sont déjà
dans une situation extrêmement difficile
qu'on va en boîte et un retour à l'école
et les rapportions était à l'époque
disent aussi que ce dispositif était
contre productif
s'il y avait des gens qui étaient déjà
en défiance vis-à-vis de l'institution
de l'éducation nationale il faut
reconquérir avec ça les leurs y ait
encore plus de l'école ont créé un
dispositif n'a pas porté ses fruits
moi je crois pas c'est une solution qui
sont aujourd'hui à la hauteur des
attentes
il faut donner plus
et il faut regarder ce qu'il fait dans
les pays scandinaves par exemple on a un
travail de de travail et convainc avec
les services sociaux avec les familles
pour les accompagner les témoins et
essayer d'anticiper le décrochage
j'essaie de voir quels sont les cas je
sais pas qui ne répondent punitive et
une faction
tu vois je le redis précarité des gens
qui souffrent déjà durablement
on va retrouver un niveau de présence à
l'école tout à fait normal que je
m'empressais été dit par contre
effectivement l'obligation d'aller à
l'école et de l'autre d'importantes mais
les femmes une fois que la voir pareil à
l'école pour regarder différemment le
parrain mois de champion ça c'est une
mesure 1 la suspension des allocations
qui rentre dans le cadre donc de la loi
sur le séparatisme officiellement
appelée projets de lois confortant le
respect des principes de la république
la droite le sénat en tout cas majorité
de droite qui durcit qu'ils sont en tout
cas durcir ce projet de loi il ya aussi
l'interdiction du port du voile pour les
accompagnatrices scolaire françois
durovray il n'ya pas quand même une
forme d'opportunisme de de la droite sur
cette question parce que je me disais et
toute façon sur la suspension des
allocations gavrelle attal a dit qu'il
n'en était pas question
concrètement l'obligation scolaire on
l'a dit c'est une responsabilité
lorsqu'on est parent on a la
responsabilité de ses enfants
je ne comprends pas pourquoi on vise
spécialement les familles modestes
la question de l'obligation scolaire
porte pour toutes les familles je peux
témoigner en tant qu'élu local ancien
maire que malheureusement l'absentéisme
peut toucher n'importe quelle famille
est donc ce ne sont pas les familles
modestes qui sont spécialement visés
nous avons bien évidemment d'autres
mesures d'accompagnement et en tant que
président du département je finance 138
éducateurs qui permettent justement de
renforcer le travail social auprès des
collèges et simplement la suspension des
allocations est un moyen supplémentaire
pour aider le collectif aider les
parents à reprendre en main l'éducation
françois durovray qu'est-ce qui peut
garantir justement que les familles
modestes vont pas être vie
et particulièrement par cette mesure
mais comme n'importe quelle mesure elle
s'applique à tous les français
je ne vois pas au nom de quoi nous
devrions y avoue avoir face à un
principe exigeant mais normal
d'obligation scolaire nous devrions
avoir des principes qui s'applique
différemment selon la catégorie des
familles la loi de la république
elle doit s'appliquer de la même façon
pour tout le monde et de la même quand
vous évoquiez tout à l'heure la question
du voile c'est là aussi la question de
l'application des principes républicains
nous avons nous observons depuis un
certain nombre d'années une dérive où
les droits individuels se construisent
et s'érige contre les principes de la
république contre les valeurs
universelles qui d'ailleurs dans le
passé étaient portés par la couche moi
ce qui me navre c'est de voir la gauche
qui a porté ces valeurs au 19e siècle
qui les abandonne aujourd'hui au profit
de catégories pour défendre des
clientèles dans la république elle doit
s'imposer à tous quelle que soit
l'origine les conditions et c'est un
principe que nous défendons au sénat
comme dans nos collectivités locales les
députés vont plancher à nouveau sur ces
modifications vous proposez vous n'avez
pas répondu par exemple sur le
durcissement de cette loi à droite et
cet opportunisme que l'on pourrait vous
reprocher ce n'est pas le durcissement
encore une fois je crains que la
république ait cédé ces dernières années
sur ses principes et ses valeurs
la droite ne dit rien d'autre ne demande
rien d'autre que l'application des
principes républicains
il n'y a aucun durcissement a demandé
tout simplement à ce que l'obligation
scolaire soit respectée et que les
principes de laïcité qui fondent les
l'organisation de notre pays depuis plus
d'un siècle soit là aussi respecter
c'est simplement la capacité de
continuer à vivre ensemble et pour vivre
ensemble il faut que chacun
s'abstiennent de faire valoir certains
certains principes qui ne relève que de
sa vie privée temps apporte vous voyez
une forme d' opportuniste
dans le camp justement de de la droite
majoritaire au sénat directeur emmanuel
macron a tellement qui était sur la
corde à droite dont jean paul électorale
que si les républicains veulent explique
t aujourd'hui doivent encore plus se
doit vite droitiser pardon pour occuper
l'espace politique mais quand j'entends
il faut que chacune et chacun respecte
la république
j'espère que les sénateurs de droite
comportera des amendements sur l'évasion
fiscale pour que chacune et chacun paye
ses impôts autant de ski les styles en
grande échelle sont aux côtés des
sénateurs de gauche pour que la loi
s'applique à tout le monde
de là on voit bien qu'il ya quelques
poids deux mesures parce qu'on nous dit
oui attention il faut supprimer les
allocations va stigmatiser populaire au
tce dans l'étude que celles et ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui le plus frappé par
l'attenté ce sont des familles dans son
mandat populaire et en même temps on
continue autorisé le financement des
écoles privées alors que nous on demande
que des cochons en public dont vous
m'avez réalité entre le discours et les
leurs et une différence aujourd'hui deux
projets de société qui est portée par la
droite
l'équipe hanté par la gauche est
aujourd'hui nous on considère par
exemple qui doit y avoir une école
obligatoire public pour tous et que
l'argent mais l'impôt la pluie la partie
non qu'elle était comme fou rire qui est
actuellement le cas et ça aussi c'est
une redingote du modèle républicain
alors comment ton à porte on lutte
contre l'absentéisme scolaire qu'après
l'attaqué ils parlent d'autres voies oui
mais qu'est ce que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure il ya d'autres voies que la
finition et la reprise de l'avocature la
l'accompagnant à cette année la mise en
place de moyens mais qui permet de
détecter les situations de décrochage
scolaire il ya une chose qu'on n'a pas
évoqué ses coûts lourde et on sait que
quand il a flotté notre colère souvent
quand vous prenez les familles ces
déductions table de travail difficiles
où les parents partis tôt le matin et
tard le soir et les enfants tél donc si
on veut aussi lutter ça il faut une
augmentation des salaires
arrêtez de pré carré des métiers et
permettre aux familles d'être au
quotidien avec les enfants pour les
accompagner là on entend très peu on
montre du doigt une catégorie de la
population alors que notre réponse qui
ne tombe pas forcément le plus utile qui
sont de formation d'accompagnement de
dispositifs de coparticipation qui
permettent aux gens de permettre à
l'enfant d'aller à l'école parce que je
le répète les classes populaires
les familles la grande majorité quelle
que soit la catégorie d'ailleurs
souhaitent que leurs enfants à l'école
pour qu'il ya d'autres voies possibles
françois durovray vous avez rochette de
la tête
vous étiez d'accord avec thomas porte
apparemment sur un point haut j'ai hoché
la tête sur qui effectivement des
familles qui ont des conditions de vie
difficiles mais ça n'enlève en rien la
question d'obligation scolaire et
peut-être que ces tags modeste plus que
d'autres considèrent justement que
l'école est la voie de la réussite pour
leur chanson et que malheureusement
certains d'entre eux mais encore une
fois ça ne touche pas uniquement les
femmes hurlaient certains d'entre eux
pour des raisons valables ou non importe
s'éloigne de l'école et donc le rôle de
la société encore une fois c'est de
rappeler la loi et y compris par la
contrainte d'accompagner les familles et
les parents à ce que leurs enfants
puissent fréquenter l'école
c'est une mesure qui est ultime ne
s'agit pas d'appliquer la suspension des
allocations familiales de façon
systématique et sans un dialogue avec
les services a bien été rappelés dans le
débat au sénat
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que la mesure
est humaniste évidemment nous sommes un
pays qui dispose de quantité d'actions à
caractère social et je l'évoquais tout
ailleurs s'agissant des éducateurs qui
sont mis en place dans mon département
je pourrais parler évidemment de toutes
les actions d'accompagnement éducatif
dans les collèges je pourrais parler du
soutien scolaire qui mis en oeuvre je
pourrais parler de quantité d'actions et
de la politique de la ville et nous
sommes heureusement un pays c'est sa
fierté qui accompagnent les familles et
notamment les familles les plus modestes
mais encore une fois il ne peut pas y
avoir dans une société
une absence totale de règles et face à
un principe aussi important que
l'obligation scolaire
il ne peut pas y avoir la démission de
la république et un enfants qui ne
fréquentent pas l'école
c'est un enfant de perdus donc moi je
préfère qu'ils reviennent à l'école avec
la menace de la suspension des
allocations plus tôt qu'il reste perdu
pour lui et pour la république juste
très rapidement sur cette question le
ministre de l'éducation jean michel
blanc car il n'a pas vraiment tranché
s'en remettant c'est ce qu'il a dit au
sénat justement comment vous réagissez
par rapport à cela
ça va un peu à l'encontre des propos de
gabriélat talent le jean michel blanquer
est manifestement dans les débats qui se
sont tenus au sénat semblait partager
une partie des arguments il a d'ailleurs
évoqué qu'il fallait que la loi
s'applique écoute la loi telle qu'elle
existe qui ne prévoit pas aujourd'hui la
suspension des allocations n'était pas
totalement impliqué moi je encore une
fois je suis pour l'application de la
loi je suis pour le renforcement de la
loi dans l'intérêt des enfants et
maintenant il ya le gouvernement semble
polyphonique sur le sujet thomas porte
très rapide je suis pas surpris de la
position de flanker laquelle mettait un
poil dans le gouvernement de carrière
s'agit de l'achat aucun mot l'islamo
gauchisme qui n'existe pas et comme
celle là encore de chef de prendre des
positions de plus en plus à droite
il faut aimer d'occuper aujourd'hui de
l'école de la situation catastrophique
dans laquelle se trouve et on l'a vu
avec l'échec de l'école du temps sur ce
troisième contenant plutôt que de venir
soutenir les amendements qui sont
absolument inefficace pour le retour à
l'école de leurs enfants qui sont ne
frappait pas trompé merci tu m'apportes
ans et bientôt ma porte porte-parole de
générations et merci à vous françois
durovray 13 est dans l air du
département de l'essonne